yo yo yo was shaking this [__] man
mercums you can catch me on bootleg cab
podcast man you already know the Vibes
man we outside Skitty
bootleg cat podcast we in Arizona
Super Bowl
America slit man we outside big Mark is
here cab was shaking bro well you've
been there pretty active man we working
man I'll stop man non-stop yeah
um what's uh for you well for people who
don't know who you are because we've
done the freestyles before but like
where are you from obviously you've been
in you represent Arizona and New York no
for sure what's a little bit of your
backstory buddy um I'm from Queens
originally man Woodside Queens um I
moved out here when I was a teenager so
I pretty much I mean I was raised out
here for real so you're raised in
Phoenix yeah yeah but you sound like
you're from New York still yeah I sound
like I'm from New York yeah I mean
you're being New York a lot nowadays too
I do be in New York a lot I see you I
think all the time now we working with
um just so we'll be doing this in demand
the style I have and everything I mean
it's just it's it works out there it's
lucrative about this a lot of a lot of
[__] that want to work a lot of
work to be done I feel like uh you're
like a perfect example of like uh work
ethic paying off like you have your
talent is like alien level but you also
have like an insane work ethic and uh
you have to have both yeah man this [__]
don't work like I mean this [__]
that's nice all the time [__]
like a rap and [__] but I'll be spending
I'll be spending hours pumping these
wraps and I mean or just I mean plotting
[__] plotting the next move we're going
through like I already know by the time
we finish one like should the Super Bowl
weekend right now Benny The Butcher said
there's a Super Bowl every year yeah
there is a Super Bowl every year yeah
but I have a cool like I killed Blake
have and then tomorrow it's a day older
than two days later it's a little bit
more old and it's like I gotta do
something yeah I was gonna say do you
put out like a pretty high amount of
content and in terms of just like your
internet game is very
Relentless right I could be replying in
everyone's tweets yeah yeah yeah and
actually it works it works yeah they
want to know what's going on man people
just want to how many tweets a day do
you send like with your [__] like
whether it's like someone com like like
could you reply to a lot of [__] yeah
yeah nah
um like on on a good day I don't even
know I I can't tell you no number like I
just wake up more than ten hell yeah
more than 10. everyday [__] every day
every day but I've been shopping I've
been chilling the last couple days wow
I've been chilling for a little bit I
mean yeah do you think that like um
because I think that I've seen that work
for you right but I also think that
you're dope right so like if you were
whack it'd be whack that you were like
spamming everybody but since you're
super dope right it's like it works out
because people it might even if you
whack it might work for a different kind
of reasons you might become a meme yeah
yeah yeah the Ice JJ Fish or whoever the
new [__] is that you know that
does these things
yeah I feel like um
I know you've been putting out projects
and [__] but I feel like you still don't
have a real album I don't
um I don't all of my albums have thus
far been um we talk about it all the
time they've been for demonstration
purposes so like I mean like the fast
lane is because I was spamming a bunch
of [__] and I spammed a fast rap and I
got a wave of fast rap lovers so yeah
and I was like okay now I gotta Demand
right so Supply and demands it's like
okay now let me make 10 songs that's
where you're doing it they're full in
this vein because now there's people
here this [__] that's buying
merch there's other fast rapping [__]
that want a verse that want to do this I
want to do that I did that for a year
and I became friends with tech N9 and
Bone Thugs so it's like okay now how
about I do something else a different
kind of style let's see what that takes
me in the next year or something like
that so it was just like everything been
for demonstration purposes
um down to this last [__] that hit man
um I wanted to show that I can make okay
[__] think I do this let me show them
I can make songs now that's why we do
the then you got the nasty [__] the
nasty business hard yeah yeah yeah yeah
and I think that's your best song yeah
what word and um like your best song
right right and um I I could see why you
would think that and um
because I made an attempt at making
songs it's like okay now let me I this
next one that we working on is about to
be crazy it's like it's it's marrying
it's marrying both the worlds and I was
like y'all know I can make a song y'all
know I could rap now this is just good
music good rapping good songs good hooks
Melodies bars you just gotta put it all
together yeah yeah yeah yeah and um it's
that time and it's already decorated and
it's beautiful
your a relationship with iced tea my
relationship with iced tea That's the
man that's the big homie bro like see
like are you like signing him or
something nah nah I'm not signing him
it's just um that's he's just a fan it's
really just a big homie this is the OG
he um he discovered me through Twitter
so I mean like like you said the
spamming and all of that [__] I got the
spamming he he was liking my [__] and he
followed me and um then from that point
I inboxed him like you hang out with
Coco huh hanging out with Coco yeah yeah
we we did all that a couple times right
I mean type [__] pool parties and [__]
like that I used to be calling [__]
out but um yeah yeah he found me on
Twitter and I dm'd him he was like I was
like um I asked me if he stayed out here
he was like yeah I got a crib out there
I'll be there I mean sometimes during
the holidays right I was like yeah I'm
trying to meet you he was like [__] I'm
trying to meet you let's let me let's
figure something out so when he when he
got in the city around like Christmas
break 2021
um he tapped in we went to his crib we
chilled for hours talked
um he made a phone call helped me get to
flex and sway all of these things that
eventually catapulted to other things
like on the radar and
um
see I will freestyle was a big part of
the iced tea and I mean um that the
10-minute joint we did yeah that [__]
was crazy yeah from there I said his
name in the bar so that just I mean it
had him really like tuned yo why did
Funk Flex take your freestyle off the
internet yo I don't know bro I don't
know why he took it down it's like um
you know when we went in the building
that day is just like we was waiting mad
long like I was the first ones it was
the first ones there the first ones
there you know I'm eager for this
opportunity yeah and his studio is like
separate from the radio station I didn't
know that it's my only so like where you
went is not where Hot 97 is okay yeah so
um I'm at that station and um
yeah man it just was [__] I waited I
waited and waited wait for everybody
then by the time it was that was the
same day that's when Cameron did that
freestyle where he's like man [__] in
there [__] with the champagne bottles
and all of that like that they walked
past us I'm in the waiting room other
[__] rap too the one of the drill cast
wrapped um black boy JB and Elite shop a
couple [__] right so I'm
waiting waiting first one the last one
to rap but it's cool I'm I eat that I I
see I know where I'm at in my career
right so it was just like of course
right um let me get there uh yo yo all
these people can't come in can't nobody
come in just you we finessed it to where
snapping could at least come in so we
could at least get content right grab
the footage and um
yeah man he was just he's just giving me
a hard time I was like I was like all
right Flex like I sent them to be so it
was like we got two beats he was like ah
nah nah we doing we're doing one beat
and it's just like damn I I created this
piece for you where I need both parts
like you know I mean part one eight is
just part one but part two is it you
marry him and this is a piece I created
I'm saying his name all through Hot 97
and all that kind of [__] and it's just
like ah nah you can't do it I'm just
like all right well can I at least wrap
them and then I mean at least wrap them
and then you decide so I wrapped them
they still decided what they said but at
least I got to wrap them so he got it so
wait so you wrapped him and they just
decided not to put them both out one
take that's so stupid and these yo I'm
just saying if you're like yo for time
purposes you only can do one but then
you end up doing both anyway so why not
that's just [__] and I wouldn't take
everything that's super true so it's not
like it's not like uh started over and
it's like ah come on come on come on
let's do one beat it's like no I mean I
went through the whole [__] and then
they deleted it yeah so they uploaded it
with no number all of the freestyle the
number so I knew immediately like
there's no number
so you know when there's a missing
number if you do remove it it doesn't
look like there's a missing number there
was never a number with myself I don't
know I don't know if it's because iced
tea called it in and it wasn't a I mean
a label thing I don't I don't know the
you know everything that comes back
there's probably it was probably because
of that yeah yeah so um that happened
and um I spoke on it publicly right and
um
then we spoke me and flex spoke oh how'd
that go it didn't really go no way it
kind of was did he call you or yeah yeah
we called iced tea or I think he called
iced tea then he called Breeze and then
he was like um yeah I was uh Markham
said nasty things about me so I really
don't I don't know what happened to it
but I'm not gonna check at this point
so it might not have been him it might
have been whoever was running the
the YouTube channel right that's a
possibility and it's a possibility
seeing that it is a possibility
I shouldn't have spoke but I did yeah
you did you definitely aired him out
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but he saw
that he saw that okay and that's why
well Markham said nasty things about me
so I don't know what happened but I'm
not going to check that but I'm not
going to check and then somebody you
know what's crazy a couple weeks later
somebody sent me my freestyle like so
bro was it back up and I'm clicking on
I'm like no it's not up but it's
unlisted so if the link you had if you
have the link already you go see it
right and it's still enlisted I think
that means there's someone who's running
the YouTube channel yeah yeah so it's
just unlisted but it got unlisted after
four months so you have to do all that
scrolling they might they might have
went in and did like YouTube channel
management you might not have been the
only thing that got on the list right
probably I just noticed myself but now
you know you burnt your Bridge with
[__] Flex
now you know what I don't I don't think
so I think I hope it was worth it I
think after all of that went and um me
still uploaded my part two that I had
that because I made sure I had it and
then me uploading like the story and the
behind the scenes and I think he kind of
got like a respect for my handle and um
I don't know man Flex is a petty guy
yeah I know I know but um he's a legend
he's only overcame but when I saw that I
kind of also I assumed it was a YouTube
like manager thing because I know how
that [__] works it's nice I um I could
admit I I jumped out the window but you
know also
you know this is the uh this is the
hip-hop um I know and love so I'm just
uh I'm just this is just my story these
are the same stories I've been
I've been reading knowing about since I
was a kid so did you and Mercury's ever
squash your problems uh me and merkules
yeah nah we I don't think so I think he
even pushed it a little bit because he
calls his fans Merc mob it was in his it
was in his bio so it's like it it never
squashed he he didn't respond to me but
he was like it was just it was just
weird how you winner but it's just just
a little subtle because then you diss
him on a song or a freestyle I did I
threw like a little did he say anything
back besides like tweets
not directly to me like it was in like
listen if there's a little baby and a
dub baby there could be a Merc and a
merkules right no no they can they can't
wasn't he the one who was mad though
he's the one who started it right he's
he started the you know what it was he
started coining his raps with Mark and
started calling his fans Merc mob and so
you know I'm now I'm in the YouTube
Community with people that are real
familiar with him so
are did you already have a Merc mob I've
been yeah I had to Mark okay I didn't
see I didn't know that no no so I had
them I'm oblivious to the Merc yeah yeah
so Merc mob you know I'm not I got this
is around the fast rapping stage okay
fans that know him [__] from
Canada right right right and he's big on
YouTube yeah they know what's up with
this guy yeah for sure and they know he
hasn't been coining his raps with Merc
in that in in that Cadence and he hasn't
been calling his fans Merc mob so um
everyone calls y'all each Merc yeah I'm
sure I'm sure yeah I'm sure but that's
that's it that's the story see I never
talked again
um
no I feel like I feel like we're gonna
do a song together
yo shout out merciles man you guys could
cover Eminem beat together yeah but he
gotta stop the Merc mob though man
that's my [__] bro he could do Merc
Maniacs you should do Merc Mania nah
that shit's way harder are you [__]
with it oh yeah brother you can do some
crazy like Hulk Hogan ass [__] merch
oh that'd be lit uh you know Maniac both
of them
so we're doing freestyle over real
American
yeah
did you see the um the was it Rolling
Stone or no the Billboard's top 50
rappers ever list um yeah I did see it
with Jay-Z Jay-Z Nicki Minaj
which is egregious uh was it Kendrick at
two NASA three yeah I don't remember the
rest
um uh Drake was eight what's up guys hey
shout out to our family at uh Bluetooth
man listen I know we always are getting
feedback about our Bluetooth interviews
they're not interviews yeah they're
commercials and we're always getting
feedback about them usually it's they're
[__] hilarious man
you know people love it when we talk
about Bluetooth but let me say this [__]
works a lot of people are like look man
I see you talking about Bluetooth but
does it work yes it works if y'all don't
know Bluetooth it's got the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis but in a
chewable form it's delivered to your
door
in a discrete package and you don't have
to go inside of a doctor's office to get
it no awkward doctor visits involved
everything is online that's right you go
to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg they will send you a month for
free a month supply of Bluetooth for
free five dollar shipping that's it and
they'll be like damn Kev
you were right bro my erections are lit
as they should be every
erection should be
as erect as possible you know you don't
want to be flaccid you don't want to be
one of those 70 30 guys you know that
means that 30 of your dicks potentially
hardness is being uh
underutilized
could you use an extra 30 hard maybe 50
hard I don't know it depends on what
you're dealing with they're dealing with
stress in your life
are you tired of having sex with your
girlfriend
hard to get it up well go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg they're going to send you a
month for free they also just drop the
mint chewable same active ingredient as
Levitra that's right so what you need to
do
I mean you don't need to do anything if
you want to you know not be as hard as
you can be that's on you but
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
and try it for free a month supply free
delivered to your door no awkward doctor
appointment needed it's all online all
right bluetooth.com
also want to shout out to our family
over at Odd Socks that's right as
someone who wears Odd Socks every day
I'll prove it to you
I'm in Arizona right now this is just
random
we got The Odd Socks underwear right
there I mean that's Odd Socks and we got
the odd Sox Basics baby yeah so look so
this was stuff about odd stocks man
um not only do they got the most
comfortable socks in the world because
they do I'm not just saying that because
they sponsor our show it's true uh they
also got some of the crazy licenses they
just got Coca-Cola uh they got Doritos
they got [__] everything they got
Scarface Godfather
uh Breaking Bad WWE we can go on and on
and on underwear socks slippers hats all
kinds of cool stuff
oddsocksofficial.com right now use the
promo code bootleg and you will save 20
off at checkout try the odd Sox Basics
if you're one of those guys who wears
other plain white branded socks plain
black socks I promise you go with the
odd Sox basics
and you will believe me but just you
will convert over they're way more
comfortable
they're way more durable
and they just they're Odd Socks why
would you wear those other socks we
could wear on socks bro stand out and be
odd go to oddsocksofficial.com use the
promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview
you know what man I feel like Nicki
Minaj
it's time for her to talk about her life
yes we see so much that she has gone we
see she's not the transparent right
right or vulnerable on records and it's
like we see all the transparency so it's
like it's just starting this time
opening up we want to hear it and run I
agree I agree so I do I think that's
what's missing with Drake too huh I
think that's that's also for me what is
missing with Drake he do it a little bit
though he added a little sprinkles I
mean I don't know where Drake stands on
social issues I don't know how he like
yeah you know I mean like I don't know
anything about Drake's stance on any
he's like he's like you know like
Michael Jordan you know Michael Jordan
was just a political a like hey man
everyone you know that's Drake Drake's
like I don't want to piss nobody off I'm
Drake
I got [__] ugly K-Swiss Nikes to sell
you saw his case wishes
them shits is egregious so what should
he do you think he should do that
something like that or do you say where
he's at I don't know
um I mean I think Drake is I think
actually Drake is probably a top five
rapper of all time
and I'm a drake hater and he owes me
money
how much you owe you 50 Grand God he was
there for what we made a bet on uh
the Warriors he said the warriors were
going to go further than the suns in the
playoffs we made it to the finals and
the Warriors got eliminated in the play
in game against the Lakers
and of course I'm not going to get my
money back
but if I see Drake again I'm just gonna
hey
can you buy coach you would say give me
10. give me 10. give me one
what you got on you right now just I'll
take it
give me like a give me an interview
pull up to 11 11. give me a five minute
interview all I need is five minutes
you explain to me on camera why you
should be higher on on this best rapper
of all time list
but um the orders is all wrong anyway
yeah it's [__] up would you like this
billboard so is this like what stock do
you put into what about Rakim where do I
put Rock in
um you know he's one of the greats man
see I think when you get into the Rock
hymns of the world and like the coochi
raps of the world and these guys who
like big daddy Kane's of the world like
these guys who like money they hate
these guys made it okay or early 90s
late 80s started the lyrics they started
the lyricism in the same way that like
it's like comparing basketball players
it's like you could like be like yo Dr J
was like an icon because he kind of
started like that flashy [__] like that
swag you know what I'm saying but Dr J
in today's League might be cam Thomas yo
I feel like you know what I mean I don't
know but it's a different error I feel
like that [__] I feel like right so it's
like even when you look at Rakim and you
look at guys like KRS one and you look
at those guys today's bar starts at NAS
to me yeah to me it's like I don't even
like when I think of rock him I'm like
man this dude without him we probably
don't have any of these other guys but
like I can't put him in my top ten right
no I can understand that I feel like for
usually people with rock him and they
top live through that and the 18th
letter was not that great and that was
like his opportunity to kind of like
have a moment in the mid 90s to mid to
late 90s yeah I don't know I don't know
that album like that yeah I mean I
bought it it was all right it was all
right there was a was it the Primo
record on there that was dope there was
a dope record on there I'm just noticing
people that have enlisted lived through
that yeah they were there right I didn't
exactly live through Nas and [__] but a
lot of people have like nods it's like
people who put Bill Russell in their top
five I can't say nothing
but I'm like come on Bill Russell wasn't
better than Wilt Chamberlain
right like in today's League Bill
Russell like Shaquille O'Neal will eat
him alive if like we're talking like in
their primes right like these things to
me like you can't put Bill Russell above
Shaq
because if they were on the same court
together it would be it would be
embarrassing
God Rest his soul
yo these interviews
LeBron will eat him alive
LeBron will score every time
and that's why I think LeBron is the
greatest of all time but you know we
don't have that discussion because
people and I love Jordan help
I love I love Jordan I love them both
um
so who's your top five [__] man this
[__] just my top five is based on what I
listen to okay so what do you I'm not I
don't mean like you're over I mean your
personal top five like in my personal
top five to seven has Pusha T in it
I Got King push around five or six I'm
gonna say mine I need you to say yours
he [__] push a t too
um my top five
that I [__] with uh I'm gonna go ahead
and say Drake Hove
um
bone
Big L
probably
maybe 50 Cent honorable mention Eminem
1999-2003.
yeah you don't want to get into that
Revival huh 1999 M got a window for me
that's my dog but yeah man you know
what's crazy is that Relapse album he
was actually rapping at a god level but
Godly that accent ruin that whole thing
yeah it was it was just things but he
was like God level lyrically doing [__]
but he did it in that accent so just no
one cares right right right the um I
know I know I know what you're talking
about though yeah the uh recovery was
all right and then he just had like a
decade there's no the music to be
murdered was music to be murdered by was
fire he had yes I'm talking about from
recovery recovery was dope but then like
Marshall Mathers LP2 was me that Revival
[__] was some of the worst [__] I ever
heard in my life
and then he he tried to double back with
the other album where he was like
dissing everybody and like super angry
what was that [__] called
that she had zero replay value zero
replay value
it was Revival yeah and then there was
the plane on the front but then music to
be murdered by was five that's cool no
no actually [__] with that album it felt
like a vintage Eminem album
Kamikaze it was like okay dude I [__]
with some Shady LP emotionally
back-to-back coasters uncle was probably
like the end in the month end of the
month I like some [__] on Encore I do
too though um but it was I know it was
then 50.
50 top five 50. yeah it's just High
yo get and and that has a window too but
that window was just so now I mean it
just did the window end with the
massacre for you
um because that's when the window ended
for me I I because Curtis was
I want to say musically it ended with
the master but the massacre was fire I
always just I continued to just like 50
Cent you know what the um what was the
name of the uh G-Unit album oh terminate
on site that shit's hard that [__] was
hard yeah what's up y'all bootleg Kev
here hey look my bookie man it's a big
weekend in sports the big game is Sunday
Chiefs versus Eagles I'm all in on the
Eagles
I like Jalen hurts over on the passing
yards over on the rushing yards anytime
touchdown score give me Dallas Goddard
anytime touchdown score give me the over
and if anyone on the Chiefs is going to
score I like that Pacheco kid I like the
little running back guy and of course
you gotta Hammer Travis Kelsey anytime
touchdown score you could do all that at
my bookie right now all right so many
props to bet on at my bookie this
weekend you can bet on the Gatorade
color that gets poured out you could bet
on the on the flip the the coin flip at
the beginning of the game all that right
now at my bookie sign up with the promo
code bootleg when you sign up they will
match your very first deposit up to one
thousand dollars with that promo code
bootleg so go to mybookie.ag sign up for
an account
promo code bootleg whatever you put in
they're gonna double it
as long as it's not more than a thousand
you put 999 dollars in they're gonna
give you another 9.99
you put a thousand in they gave you
another thousand by the way if you do
the 9.99 why not just do the full
thousand you cheap bastard anyway my
bookie right now man it's a big weekend
also I just would like to point out
everyone should be putting some of that
money sprinkling a little bit of that
action on the Phoenix Suns to win the
championship this year because we have
Kevin Durant oh yeah oh yeah my bookie
sign up with that promo code bootleg
also shout out to our family at hardean
Harding Las Vegas Yes you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
the customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with hard
Dean you got to follow him at Harding
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot
them a follow on Instagram while you're
at it go to their website
hardinglasvegas.com so much fly gear so
much fly weed what are we talking about
baby shout out to hardine man that's the
family man go if you're in Vegas pull up
on them man Jardine Las Vegas
that was around the that was around the
officer Ricky like when he was
terrorizing [__] like you know I also
like that um the internet stuff I like
what 50 I just I just like 50. he's he's
entertaining this is why you like to
troll people on the internet no I don't
be trolling nobody on the internet
sometimes
they be trolling me you chose front Flex
on the internet I ain't troll from the
flag he did you said a nice things about
him that's rolling
we're gonna get you back on there me and
flex good no no we're good I don't know
I'm gonna see Flex again one day man one
day it's gonna be low and he's gonna be
like pass
nah I think you're gonna [__] with me
he's gonna be like send him over to DJ
self across the street now I think Flex
[__] would be weird he gonna have a
healthy um healthy respect for what I
got he's a nice guy
um so when is your next what's like next
uh so next um should we working on it
right now I gave you a little um told
you on the phone who I was on
dealing with and um yeah we had a
conversation today we're just working on
that the album is actually done
um waiting on a verse from a Wu member
it's lit which one nothing man no not
meth
guess you got two more guesses let's see
the ray Corner Ghost Face none of them
expect a day oh wow yeah yeah yeah shout
out to that he invited me to some of the
greatest hey inspector deck in my
opinion go ahead upon the time has
a top three verse of all time and the
top ten verse of all time above the
clouds and and Triumph work come on Word
also Eminem's verse on we all die one
day on Obie trice's album
he's [__] crazy
it might be inspector deck I just I
can't even dive into that right now
but a Triumph is a top three verse of
all time it might be one
it might be one that's five
which the what you talking about the
remix of the year
it's cool as a song or as a verse it's
as a song it's an all-time great hip-hop
song for sure but I think New York State
of Mind is the greatest rap song of all
time
New York State of Mind yeah it's my
favorite rap song of all time from
Illmatic yeah
so inspector deck I was thinking Empire
I was like what respect attack inspect
the day nice did you ever get his album
uncontrolled substance I haven't heard
that up
not a lot of people did but it was all
right no not yet I haven't heard it
um and the inspected that [__] is crazy
because um I [__] with the producer
shout out to PA Dre
um he produced inspector deck's last
album and it was a song that needed to
be finished right he had to turn the
album in like next couple of days so the
producers since he [__] them he sent me
to join us inspect the deck and thems
gorilla names huh yeah yeah yeah so um
did a verse on that and uh yeah that's
that's how I mean that relationship
started have you hung out with gorillin
M's in Coney Island yet
um I have we went to um one of his
shoots basically brought us out to one
of his gorilla them shoes and then he
had a pop-up shop I pulled up too
um hooked up with Steve so any other
features on the new uh on this one
um
Daisy land you know Daisy Lynn she's
from L.A she's nice she's fine you gotta
check out okay and uh Mega ran of course
yeah yeah Mega Rand is on there is he
rapping about video games I gotta read
his verse to see there might be a video
game Ballroom what about wrestling I
gotta read I don't know the verse by
heart I know he's I know he snapped but
I got it I mean check into them balls
again to see would you do a collab
project with anyone
has that ever like would you do like a
fool absolutely hell yeah what about
like you and um cocolino
Chris Coke yeah
I would like to do that um that'd be
hard he's about to be here word now it's
lit yeah
um I want to do one with him industry I
I don't even know somebody though you
know somebody that makes sense right I
could borrow there's a bunch of [__]
so I mean whoever whoever I build with
not me I don't really got it like you
could do one with lazy bone look me a
lazy bone I feel like I feel like lazy
bone did a whole album with Mr Capone
before what it was either him or busy
bone I think it was busy I think it was
busy that [__] was doing collab
Chicano rap albums
and all kinds of high power record [__]
coming out I'll say what the [__] oh
[__] I remember calling Steve Lopez like
Steve he's like bro I ain't got nothing
to do with that [__]
now a lot of um as far as the ogs man
yeah yeah not me me and lazy bone
that'll be oh I don't [__] with that me
and crazy bones something like that me
and Craig have you met crazy
um I met all of them except busy I seem
busy busy is a wild guy word I picked
him up in a 91 Honda Accord from the
airport in Boise Idaho in 2009. he was
probably cool he was tweaked out bruh
and that night I interviewed him outside
of a bar and it's on YouTube and I was a
kid yeah
I was literally like I was literally
like he was talking and I was literally
like
because he was like it was wild shots
are busy Legend
busy bone is a legend [__] it's not the
Busy Bone man East 99 one of the
greatest albums it is yeah it is one of
the greatest yeah this was one of the
greatest top 25 for sure no word
definitely you got bone that's your
favorite bone album yeah yeah yeah that
um when you were listening to bone was
your mom freaking out because of all the
Ouija board [__]
nah Because by the time I was listening
to Bone I did nothing was real time you
know you went back I had to yeah how do
you I'm 31. yeah I'm 35 95 I'm full
so it's not like I'm really jamming out
like when by the time I'm jamming out 14
15 it's 2005 2006. it's like ludicrous
yeah so I'm but I'm doing my Bone Thugs
my death rolls on the Big L so
everything is homework essential respect
that I mean so well you got a new
project coming soon yeah featuring
inspector deck now I mean smoke doesn't
might be on there too
smoke just a good man yeah yeah so it's
lit I mean we're going crazy trying to
think who else you should be rapping
with
I like that smoked dizza yeah yeah yeah
you and them should do a record nah yeah
we got we gotta we got to do something
for like just me and him that'd be crazy
appreciate you pulling up my dog you
already know man